أنا دانا سانتيس، مدربة حركات التنفس والجسم
والعقل في الرياضات الاحترافية
عندما تنهي يومك وتسترخي على
الأريكة، ما رأيك في جعل هذا الوقت
أكثر استرخاءً مع هذه تمارين التمدد الثلاث
التي ستساعدك على استرخاء جسمك
بعد يوم طويل في المرة الأولى  التمدد هو
شكل بسيط من الحمام، لذا
سترفع ساقك اليمنى للأعلى ثم
تسحب ساقك اليسرى للخلف بقدر ما تشعر
بالراحة إذا كان بإمكانك إسقاط تلك
الركبة على طول الطريق، فافعل ذلك ثم
استقيم، وإذا  يمكنك أن تبدأ في
الانحناء قليلاً وستشعر
بتمدد كبير في أردافك وقد
تبدأ في الشعور ببعضه في ظهرك
ثم ابق هنا وتنفس إذا كان هذا
يشعرك بالراحة يمكنك حتى الاسترخاء على طول
الطريق وفقط  اجلس هنا
ويمكنك الاسترخاء في هذه التمددات طالما
أنك ترغب فقط في التأكد من قيامك بالجانب
الآخر، التمدد التالي هو
تحرير رباعي وتمديد ثني الورك وبالتالي
ستأخذ ساقك اليمنى للأمام
ثم قدمك اليسرى  تستريح على
الأريكة وستبقى في هذا الوضع، ثم قم بالزفير، وقم
بإنزال الضلوع
لأسفل، ثم قم بدس الحوض تحتها ثم يمكنك استخدام
الأريكة أو طاولة القهوة الخاصة بك للحصول على الدعم
أثناء تثبيتك على هذا الوضع والتنفس
ثم إضافة القليل إليه  ارفع
ذراعك اليسرى للأعلى لأنك
تريد إطالة هذه المنطقة بأكملها
التي تمتد ثم انحنى جانبًا
إلى اليمين ثم احتفظ بهذا لمدة
ثلاثة أنفاس تقريبًا، فقط تأكد من أنك
لا تدع حوضك يميل إلى
الأمام، فأنت في الواقع  محاولة
إمالة حوضك إلى الأسفل لأن هذا هو
المفتاح لإطلاق عضلات الورك هذه
ثم بعد 3 إلى 5
أنفاس تعيدها إلى هنا، ارفع هذه
القدم للأعلى وبالطبع لديك جانبان
انتقلا إلى الجانب الآخر
للتمدد النهائي  ستضيف القليل من
الالتواء، لذا للحصول على الدعم، ضع ساعدك الأيسر
لأسفل على أريكتك، واثنِ ركبتيك
حتى تكون في وضع
القرفصاء قليلًا، ثم قم بمد ذراعك اليمنى
للأمام واستنشق بينما تدور لأعلى وأنت تتحرك
لفرد ساقك اليمنى،
والآن يمكنك تمديد أوتار الركبة وتمديد أسفل
الظهر، ثم هذا الالتواء اللطيف
الذي يفتح صدرك ويمنحك
بعض الدوران الصحي في منتصف الظهر، خذ ثلاثة
إلى خمسة أنفاس
هنا، ثم قم بالزفير، ثم قم بإسقاطه، وافعل
نفس الشيء على الجانب الآخر